chez oracle a tout de suite nos invités
autour de la table musique c'est parti
il est l'animateur qui a fait plus de
chaîne au monde qui n'est pas comment le
pib du japon pour soi même en terre
c'est benjamin castaldi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est à toi merci bravo on a tout donné
elle est née au maroc elle est
magnifique elle aime les boulettes
patoche et les boulettes de pâte hcma
l'événement fera ce qu'on a que depuis
1986 et ne rate pas une occasion d'être
lourd mais rate la plupart de ces
ballons les biens de m c'est jean-michel
terre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et le cerveau d'un homme de 80 il est
tellement mauvais en drag qui
collectionne non pas les râteaux mais
les tractopelles c'est maxime galy
[Applaudissements]
il est amer
il a failli tomber sur moi on repart il
est tellement énervée qu'il est capable
de pousser un coup de gueule contre
lui-même innacor de dieu grec et un
visage d'un sandwich grec super nes
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or c'est mieux pour tout le monde
qu'elle n'était pas sortie oui elle est
toujours ce qu'elle pense sauf si ça
concerne m6 souhaite t elle quand on
commence une phrase elle a fini en
général la dette us l'année suivante en
revanche elle est contente d'être là et
en revanche isabelle morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quelle descente des messieurs qui y sera
tête de ma mère le temps qu'elles
descendent les escaliers alors on doit
rendre l'antenne merci à tous toujours à
2 jouera devant là elle a lu plus de
livres que tous les chroniqueurs de tpm
paix réuni dans la vie c'est un peu une
touche à tout sauf à jean michel maire
merci d'accueillir geraldine page
[Applaudissements]
un centre de bronzage et c'est en le
croyant que le poisson de france télécom
a eu l'idée de rebaptiser sa société
orange
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà quelqu'un dont il était costaud
c'est vrai et même le public au plus bas
je crois qu'on a tous mal où j avais tu
peux revenez à votre chéri bienvenue au
juste prix a dit
[Applaudissements]